well as they make reference to before
through my father's craftsmanship I
write every sentence with a sense that
it had better be the very best I'm
capable of because I had an exalted
sense of the lasting value of what I
work I mean my own work I believe is is
written in such a way that can be read
ten years after a righted or 20 years
after I write it with with the same
sense of the presence I bring through
prose to the subject and writing about I
never wanted to write ever even when I
was young I'm 76 now when I was 26 fifty
years it was the same thing I never
wanted to write topically I never wanted
to write about something that was in the
news today therefore that was why I was
getting into print because I was writing
about something current I always stayed
away or tried to stay away from anything
that I thought wasn't going to thanks to
my careful chronicling or prose writing
that wouldn't be able to be read years
hence with the same interest on the
readers part as whatever the reader
might bring to what I wrote immediately
after it was published so I didn't want
to be a journalist in that sense in fact
I never was a very I don't think I was
ever celebrated as a journalist however
I've been celebrated a reason I'm on
this show whatever brings me to this
show is not because I was a
prize-winning journalist I wasn't the
kind of person that win a Pulitzer
because I wasn't doing that kind of work
what I was trying to do when I was on a
newspaper and continually throughout
where I am today was trying to bring a
sense of presence to what album writing
about to a reader who were would
otherwise not know about what I'm
writing about and therefore I was trying
to write in a way that was more identify
about with fiction writers with the
great short story writers the great
novel writers or the great playwrights I
wanted to write stories the only thing I
wanted to bring to the kind of stories
that I do and have always done is
reality in the sense of the real name of
the person
and situations that are verifiably true
I believe that dumb
I believe that reality can be fantastic
if you know people really well if you
can spend the time with people and get
deeply into their character into their
sensibilities you can write what seems
to be fiction and it's not one of the
reasons I take so long I'm hardly a
prolific person when you consider I've
been working you know for more than a
half-century and I have eleven books and
three of them are rather short and the
reason it takes me so long is it I have
to know the people very well I have to
establish a kind of relationship that
goes beyond just professionalism that
becomes personal now though I mean I'm
not writing for the personal approval of
the people I'm writing about I'm not I I
do maintain as a writer the the
prerogative of being fully in control
control of the manuscript but on the
other hand I am so sensitive to the
people I'm writing about and I know them
so well and can't believe I can actually
know how they think not what they say as
I'm tipsy but you know but I want to I
want to know and do think I do know how
they think and I bring that interior
monologue into my prose it is in direct
quotation it is how people think and
when you have to spend that time knowing
people time passes so much of my time is
getting to know people long before I'm
writing anything even before I'm making
notes I mean the last book I writers
life took me about 10 10 years the book
before that unto the sons 10 years thy
neighbor's wife published in 1982
another 10 years the book on the
gangster family I hung out with
published in 1972 called only father
that was also 9 years the book on the
New York Times I had a whole 10-year
experience on the paper before I wrote
about it so I really do not write a lot
but what I do right I know what I'm
writing about I know the people I'm
writing about so the book that the books
hold up so they're being reissued as
they are this next year to old books on
our life father and thy neighbor's wife
published as you said 1913 1982 in 1970
two are being reissued without a word
change now am i taking pride in that yes
the way it's down below I hope not but
what I'm trying to do is give you an
understanding of my value system as a
writer which is to write in a way that
can hold up as my father when he made
suits said make sure the buttons don't
fall off the stitching has to be perfect
hand stitching not done quickly or
casually because it had to withstand
time and I that's what I took from my
father
well the sense of wonderful wonderment
about who I was in this rather alienated
society that I described to you earlier
Who am I and also I believe that while
we were a most ordinary family and
rather ordinary circumstances the town
is a small town Ocean City New Jersey
not known for very very much it's it's
it was a seashore resort in the catering
mostly in the summertime to people from
the Philadelphia area I never saw people
from New York down there but what drew
me to writing was that in the world war
ii period when i was just not even a
teenager i thought there was an
international story just in our little
address in that little tailor shop and
dress shop and the apartment upstairs
which is where we live but during the
world war ii period my father having as
i told you
italian brothers fighting in the italian
army against the u.s. brought to this
little location in ocean city a sense of
awareness about the international event
the world war ii event and how this
tailor was every night connected through
shortwave radio listening to the war
news and that where the war was being
brought into our living room at 11
o'clock at night or midnight and i
thought here is a story of people living
a kind of double life or triple life in
the daytime the tailor my father and my
mother who ran the dress shop talking to
the american people selling them closed
my father would sometimes as a tailor
not make suits because there's a
shortage of material during world war ii
and what he do often is just alter the
suits of soldiers or maybe shall sew on
a shirt maybe a guy was promoted from
corporal to sergeant and my father would
sew on
and i'd see here are these american
soldiers were fighting italy and here's
my father sewing on the chevron another
what a connection to the international
event the tailor who come to middlee and
who has sentiments toward his the safety
of his brothers and may be privately
praying for the survival of his ville
as Allied bombers and Allied troops from
the American the British the Canadians
were moving right through his village
and the kind of curious complex
situation of a tailor in a small town a
protestant town I thought it's
interesting some things should right
about that well some day I did write
about that was called on to the sons and
it's gonna be on HBO there the director
writer and Stanley Tucci the actor is
directing this and writing this now as I
speak to you well here is this story
back in 1943 in the mind and eyes of a
of a rather obscure Lee defined eleven
year old me and now in 2008 or 2009
there will be this HBO series inspired
by the flawed and rather insecure
mentality of a kid and so there's really
again a reaffirmation of how things are
perceived in one way at a certain time
and later on are translated a half a
century later in this case to what will
be an HBO series
you